corona krise das bedeutet für viele
frauen gerade zurück in alte
rollenbilder verschiedene studien zeigen
das ist vor allem die frauen sind die
einspringen wenn zum beispiel die
kinderbetreuung oder die schule
geschlossen hat dass sie es sind die
dann die betreuung übernehmen oder das
homeschooling und sowas wie
gleichberechtigung oder karriere auf der
strecke bleiben
darum soll es heute gehen und natürlich
könnt ihr wie immer auch mitdiskutieren
und eure fragen stellen kostet sie
einfach hier unten ins kommentarfeld
jetzt erstmal gibt aber eva schiller
einen einblick in den corona alltag von
familien
sie sind die heldinnen und gleichzeitig
die verliererinnen in der krise
berufstätige mütter ich glaube das ist
gerade extrem ist möglich eine rolle
rückwärts machen in sachen emanzipation
früher waren das die berühmten drei
kinder küche kirche heute sind es eher
die drei haas nämlich haushalt home
office und homeschooling sie waren
einmal eine moderne familie beide
berufstätig die betreuung der drei
kinder gerecht aufgeteilt doch in der
korona krise hat sich das traditionelle
rollenmuster eingeschlichen jetzt
schmeißt dann reif haushalt und kinder
während ihr mann als hauptverdiener
morgens das haus verlässt gerade wenn
wir hier streit hatten wegen irgendwas
liegt dann einfach heulend in meinem
bett und kann einfach nicht mehr und ich
bin eigentlich jemand der immer kann
normalerweise also ich bin eigentlich
ziemlich unkaputtbar aber ich bin
ziemlich kaputt die korona krise
verschärft was vorher schon war um die
kinder zu betreuen haben fast doppelt so
viele frauen ihre arbeitszeit reduziert
als männer da findet eine rolle
rückwärts stadt sagt geschäftsführerin
christina sontheim leben
die gefährdet was frauen über jahrzehnte
erkämpft haben
wir werden uns in ein zwei jahren fragen
wo bitte sind denn all die weiblichen
führungskräfte und dann wird uns einfach
ach ja stimmt die sind ja zum teil noch
im home office oder die sind aus der
ganzen karriere schiene ausgestiegen die
haben nämlich in der zeit mit den
kindern zu hause geknetet und den
männern den rücken freigehalten
sie betreut ihre kinder abwechselnd mit
dem vater hat in der firma ein
kinderzimmer eingerichtet um ihre
mitarbeiter bei der betreuung zu
unterstützen
wie selbstverständlich die politik davon
ausgeht dass frauen alle
schultern zeige der muttertags bot der
regierung
man hat ein bisschen das gefühl auch
weil die politik antworten schuldig
bleibt dass die auch wie
selbstverständlich davon ausgehen dass
sich so an dieser situationen an dieser
selbstverständlichkeit es sind die
frauen die zu hause bleiben und diese
situation mit auffangen dass sich daran
auch so schnell nichts ändern wird das
biergärten die bundesliga freizeitparks
öffnen schulen und kindergärten aber nur
langsam in den normalbetrieb gehen macht
auch andrea reisch wütend ich habe die
befürchtung dass wir nach dieser krise
wieder viel mehr hausfrauen klassische
hausfrauen haben und das hat ja ganz
großen rattenschwanz es geht ja nicht
darum das dann bei vielen wieder die
karriere oder die berufliche tätigkeit
still liegt sondern auch renten in
sozialen medien präsentieren sie und
andere mütter der politik eine
symbolische rechnung für unentgeltliche
betreuungsarbeit dass die frauen dafür
massiv angefeindet werden sagt auch
etwas über das rollenverständnis in
deutschland und per skype zugeschaltet
ist nährt die präsidentin des
wissenschaftszentrums berlin
soziologen professor jutta allmendinger
am freilinger holz im moment sie haben
gesagt sie befürchten eine entsetzliche
re tradition ali sierung wir sprechen
von drei jahrzehnten die wir verlieren
wie zeigt sich dass in den aktuellen
studien naja wie kommt es zu diesen drei
jahrzehnten vielleicht zunächst mal ich
vergleiche mein sohn 26 und seine
umgebung mit der meiner mutter und
zunächst mal meine mutter hat aufgehört
zu arbeiten als ich als ältestes kind
zur welt kommen soll ist noch nicht ganz
soweit aber die hausarbeit ist schon
ungleich verteilt auch der und
entsetzlich dass kam dadurch zustande
weil der normative raum also dass man
selbstverständlich war bei meiner mutter
natürlich auch mal meiner großmutter
heute alles andere als
selbstverständlich ist weil die jungen
frauen eben auch karriere machen möchten
die haben keine bildungs unterschiede
mehr zu den jungs
meist besser in schulen haben ungefähr
die gleiche anzahl von abschlüssen an
universitäten auch in der beruflichen
bildung und sie wollen ein stück eigenes
leben das ist eben in dieser krise zu
einem sehr großen teil genommen worden
also dass wen sich in den aktuellen
studien dass es da parallelen gibt
sicher wenn ich jetzt einfach die
aufgabenverteilung zwischen männern und
frauen innerhalb eines haushaltes dann
kann ich auch mehr als 10.000 personen
zurückgreifen die geantwortet haben wir
haben ein alltag ohne alltag de
geschaltet und wir können 2010 das erste
ist dass frauen mit ihrer arbeitszeit
die bezahlt ist extrem zurückgehen und
entsprechend mit ihr unbezahlten arbeit
nämlich der betreuung von kindern der
betreuung und partnern der betreuung des
haushalts deshalb der sportler rennen
sorgt zum freundinnen und freunden all
dieser unbezahlten arbeit nach oben
gehen das ist sozusagen das eine die
ungleichverteilung der arbeitszeit
bezahlt unbezahlt und das zweite ist die
zufriedenheit die bei frauen
insbesondere bei jungen frauen
insbesondere dramatisch sinkt und das
ist nicht nur die unzufriedenheit mit
der arbeit sondern es ist auch die
unzufriedenheit mit der familie und es
ist die unzufriedenheit mit ihrem
gesamten leben
das bezeichne ich schon als traumatisch
das sehen hier durchaus an den
kommentaren unsere user anders deswegen
würde ich sagen wir gucken mal direkt
rein und sprechen dann darüber hier sagt
zum beispiel nino bei youtube ich finde
das hier nicht gut dass und das
rollenbild man arbeitet frau kümmert
sich um kinder direkt negativ
dargestellt wird es gibt viele die das
freiwillig machen
brigitte schreibt auch bei youtube die
frauen sind auch dann gleichberechtigt
wenn sie halbtags arbeiten gehen und
steven schreibt back to the roots früher
war eben doch vieles besser also bitte
zurück mit den traditionellen
rollenbildern warum sehen sie das anders
ich schreibe brigitte und steven
überhaupt gar kein rollenbild vor darum
geht es mir nicht
die sendung heute heißt
gleichberechtigung und ich möchte nur
dass frauen das was viele frauen sagen
was ich weiter mehrheit komfort und sagt
dass sie eben auch das recht haben auf
ein stück eigenes leben das recht hatten
auf unabhängigkeit vom staat von dem
versorgen den partner dass sie das
erreichen möchten und dass sie das
erreichen möchten ohne auf kinder zu
verzichten und von daher geht dieser
lebensentwurf und andere geht auch der
eine bringt einen abhängigkeiten es
kommen möchten das kann man nicht
möchten und der andere schafft eben ein
stück anderes legen also im prinzip die
freiheit sich auch zu entscheiden was
möchte ich möchte ich karriere machen
oder möchte ich eventuell ja vielleicht
auch zu hause bleiben und dass wir auch
im prinzip meine meine nächste frage
das gilt nicht für männer wie für frauen
kriegen wir das sehr einseitig das ist
männern möglich ist aber frauen eben
nicht was glauben sie denn woran liegt
das dass ist jetzt gerade vor allem die
frauen sind die einspringen in der krise
das liegt daran dass sie meistens
wesentlich weniger bedienen das ist ja
eine diskussion die wir die ganze zeit
haben
systemrelevante berufe wesentlich
niedrigeres einkommen
es liegt daran dass sie meist teilzeit
erwerbstätig sind das heißt auch und
niedrigeres einkommen pro monat weil es
eben weniger stunden sind und dann wird
ganz leicht im haushalt so eine rechnung
aufgemacht
na ja wir haben den geringeren verlust
unseres haushalts reinkommen wenn du
einfach zu hause bleibt und nicht
erwerbstätig ist der mann da sagt an
dieser zustand den sie da jetzt
beschreiben über die gleichberechtigung
in deutschland das zeigt dass wir
eigentlich unerledigte hausaufgaben mit
in die krise genommen haben unerledigte
hausaufgaben war beispielsweise im
steuerrecht welches viel mehr
ausgerichtet ist auf wenn zwei berliner
haushalt mit zwei ungefähr gleichen
stundensätzen das ist unser ehegatten
städte nicht die kostenlose
mitversicherung ist ein weiteres
beispiel ein drittes beispiel ist dass
wir versuchen die weiblichen erwerbs
kann
deren anzupassen jene der männer als wir
bekommen nur im moment eine
gleichstellung zwischen frauen den
männern hin in dem die frauen vollzeit
ihr leben lang überhaupt tätig sind
das kann auch nicht der weg sein wir
müssen die arbeitszeiten und männern
etwas niedriger die arbeitszeiten von
frauen etwas höher schalten und damit
starten wenn der gleiche verteilung von
bezahlter und unbezahlter arbeit und wir
müssen das wahrmachen was die ganze zeit
gefordert wird nämlich jenen die extrem
verantwortungsvolle jobs machen in
krankenhäusern in kitas in schulen in
lohn zu geben der dieser verantwortung
entspricht und nicht nur den ablösung
empfehlen wir denn dann eigentlich
wirklich zurück in alte rollenbilder
oder muss man nicht eigentlich
konstatieren ja auch schon vor der krise
waren wir da noch nicht so weit wie wir
eigentlich schlecht sein sollten dass
wir jetzt sehen so eine krise ist auch
wie ein brennglas dessen was schon
vorgängig erreicht worden
das nicht erreicht aber nie uns jetzt
mal skandinavische länder
da haben wir eine wesentliche gleichere
verteidigung der eltern monate nach der
geburt von kindern zwischen müttern und
zwischen vätern in deutschland haben wir
nur diese zusätzlichen zwei monate die
dann auch von männern zunehmend mehr von
hälfte der männer langsam genommen wird
das sind tradierte mechanismen die in so
einer krise natürlich sofort boxen und
was soll ich jetzt sagen was erwarte ich
im moment sehen wir diese tradition ali
sierung mit allen darf nicht nur mit den
daten des wissenschaftszentrums auch mit
den mannheimer daten auch mit dem daten
des sozioökonomischen panels aber es
liegt an uns was wir daraus machen und
dass wir positiv daraus lernen können
das steuersystem zu ändern endlich das
ist seit jahrzehnten im gespräch wir
können daraus lernen dass wir die ganzen
wirtschaftsförderungen jetzt rein gegen
industrie so schneiden dass sie männern
und frauen gleichermaßen zugute kommt im
englischen sagt man dazu gender
budgeting danken nicht nur da können wir
gleich auch noch auf jeden fall darüber
sprechen das wird noch ein teil sein ich
würde aber vielleicht vorab darauf
schauen was man jetzt auch gerade in der
krise jetzt nicht nur generell
sondern auch gut in der krise ändern
müsste eigentlich und hier sind ein paar
kommentare aufgelaufen die vielleicht
ganz gut in die richtung passen und zwar
zum beispiel einer von pinien bei
facebook die sich vor allem dazu äußert
dass die regierung es nicht und sich
nicht um die betreuung und die
interessen von kindern schert sie
wundert das nicht im geringsten was
gerade so hier los ist das angebot der
schulen ist zurzeit eine große
lachnummer immer schön die verantwortung
an die eltern in klammern mieter
abwälzen schreibt sie du bist äußert
sich ähnlich die sagt dann machen die
kitas endlich wieder auf und ich würde
würde die frage gerne mal an sie
weitergeben was müsste denn jetzt gerade
akut anders gemacht werden um diese
situation für frauen zu verbessern
also zunächst mal erlauben sie mir doch
noch mal einen kurzen blick zurück ich
finde das vollkommen unmöglich man
erstmal überhaupt da die familien
gedacht wird also zu wenig spätem
zeitpunkt die frage von kitas will
spätem zeitpunkt habe von schulen in den
blick gerückt ist
da waren wir mit der wirtschaft weiter
tragen und wie wenig das entsetzt mich
auch ein wenig innovative modelle wieder
gefahren sind neben es einrichten können
ich lehre viel ich sehe dass meine
studierenden oft jetzt ziemlich blöde
dastehen weil ihnen natürlich das
einkommen weggefallen ist in dem sie oft
ihr studium zu finanzieren haben die
lücken durchaus sich bewerben um dann
kinder auch nur abzuholen für zwei drei
stunden die eltern zu entlasten es geht
ja nicht nur um geld es geht ja auch um
zeit die junge mütter extrem mal für
sich brauchen um sie konzentrieren zu
können um mal durchlaufen zu können aber
auch um ein gutes leben mit ihrem
partner zu haben das hat man ja auch
nicht vergessen
also es gibt andere möglichkeiten die
kindertagesstätten so zu öffnen dass sie
gerade in den gebieten offen sind diese
besonders stark brauchen
es gibt möglichkeiten andere gebäude zu
nutzen
das was wir in anderen sektoren wie in
der gastronomie in vielen anderen
innovative konzepte haben uns hier
vollkommen gefehlt und es wird höchste
zeit dass wir von ihr sind mega
unregelmäßigen unterricht ganz wenig
planbar ist
der oft nur zwei stunden am tag betrifft
und eigentlich eine lage ob auch noch
verschlimmert im vergleich zu der der
wie die mühe hatten regelmäßig sondern
muss aber dass wir das endlich auch mehr
kontinuität transparenz und eltern
freundlichkeit aber damit auch
kinderfreundlichkeit sitzen das ist mir
ganz wichtig ein weiterer kritikpunkt
der geäußert wird aktuell auch im netz
der heißt dass frauen viel weniger
sichtbar sind in der krise zum beispiel
als experten aber als krisenmanagerin
da haben sich einige zu geäußert im netz
und was daran für reaktionen darauf kam
das schauen wir uns jetzt mal kurz an
gibt es unter virologen eigentlich auch
frauen oder ist das ein rein männlicher
ausbildungsberuf in einer inter
nationalen pandemie mit einer der
wahrscheinlich größten kommenden
wirtschaftskrisen war die korrekte denn
der regierung auch meine größte sorge
wenn aber die steuer töpfe mit denen
dieser blödsinn bezahlt wird bald leer
sind bin ich diese sorge los es ist doch
vollkommen scheiß egal ob das ein mann
eine frau ein schwarzer weißer dicker
dünner mit glatze oder mit haaren ist
hier geht es um fachliche kompetenz
sonst nichts
ich denke die lage ist zu ernst als dass
wir ernsthaft über ihre geduld themen
nachdenken sollten alleine frauen
entscheiden lassen was
gleichberechtigung ist hier brauchen wir
eine gleichberechtigte debatte aktuell
ist diese debatte zu fast 100 prozent
von frauen dominiert die perspektive von
männern und auch frauen mit anderen
background wird hier meist nicht
berücksichtigt so dass jetzt einiges
drin über das wir reden müssen
lassen sie uns mal mit dem vorwurf der
gedöns themen beginnen also es sei jetzt
nicht der richtige zeitpunkt über
gleichberechtigung zu sprechen das kommt
in so kommentaren relativ häufig da
werden sie ja wahrscheinlich relativ
deutlich widersprechen oder ich wage
mich nur wenn wir das tatsächlich als
gedöns kennzeichnen wie wir dann unsere
kranken pflegen wie überhaupt die
krankenhäuser aufrechterhalten
wie überhaupt unseren schulbetrieb
aufrecht erhalten wie wir andere
schlüsselindustrien aufrecht erhalten
wenn sie frauen die 50 prozent der
erwerbsquote immer einstellen ich des
arbeitsvolumens
der bearbeiteten stunden aus dem
arbeitsmarkt sehen ist die deutsche
wirtschaft weg wenn sie das als gedöns
kennzeichen und wenn sie die erziehungs
arbeiten von frauen der kinder und die
pflege zu hause privat unbezahlt der
eltern noch wegrennen dann frage ich
mich mal dass der zustand unserer
gesellschaft originäre absolut und dass
das heißt also sie sagen genau jetzt ist
eigentlich genau der zeitpunkt wo man
darüber sprechen muss oder der es immer
oder aber ist er jetzt ganz besonders
der fall was würden sie denn machen wenn
frauen nicht die ganzen arbeit machen
würden
also ich denke dass in der tat die
politik die ganze frage von familien von
schulen im übrigen auch das schicksal
von kindern welches jahr geprägt wird in
den ersten zwei drei vier jahren das
sagt die ganze bildungsforschung massiv
die ganze entwicklungspsychologie die
lassen sie zuhause teilweise in
elternhäusern die kein deutsch sprechen
das wäre gar nicht schlimm wenn sie
gleichermaßen in jetzt wirken während wo
deutsch gesprochen werden würde
da sehen sie die dramatischen folgen in
zehn und 15 jahren
das ist verantwortungslos was wir hier
machen nicht nur für die mütter die
karriere knie gehabt
das kam mir in ihrem vorspann wunderbar
aus sondern auch für die kinder wo man
es eben erst in zehn jahren sehen
ein weiterer kommentar den wir jetzt
gerade gehört haben da ging es ja um das
thema ja schauen wir zu sehr aus aus
frauensicht auf das thema
gleichberechtigung fehlt uns da ein
bisschen die männliche perspektive auch
nun ja zunächst mal war ja in den
vorliegenden beitrag angesprochen worden
warum brauchen wir überhaupt frauen und
der experten ist es doch bislang ist
wissen und ob das wissen von einem mann
oder einer frau dargestellt wird ist
doch vollkommen egal
dazu zwei antworten die erste antwort
ist frauen gehören auch zu den
brillantesten wissenschaftlerinnen und
auch deren kompetenzen zu verzichten ist
schon ziemlich sorglos würde ich mal
sagen und zum zweiten ist natürlich dass
die lebensrealitäten der kommissionen
wie sie auch immer zusammengesetzt sind
schon auch gerade in so ad hoc
stellungnahmen
mit einfließen wir haben das gesehen in
ad hoc stellungnahmen von großen
akademien und das durchschnittliche
alter 64 jahre war da können sie nicht
erwarten dass den kindern die türe
klopft und sagte papa war erzählt mir
doch mal hier und da
da ist diese erfahrung nicht dauernd von
daher werden solche themen auch weniger
dann platziert und wir sehen auch in der
wissenschaft eine arbeitsteilung
zwischen männern und frauen dahin gehen
dass will mehr frauen in der psychologie
in der entwicklungs pädagogik sind als
in anderen fächern und auch deshalb
lohnt sich diverse zusammensetzung und
diverse rakos in tanz von frauen in den
mädchen auch aber weit über die mädchen
genossen und dann dieser weitere
kommentare der eben sagt die männliche
perspektive die wird da vergessen wie
stehen sie dazu
die männliche perspektive wird insofern
vergessen als wenn wir befragungen
machen und ich bin wissenschaftlerinnen
möchte auch jetzt hier nicht aus dem
nähkästchen irgendwie jude aus meiner
blase mit ihnen diskutieren sondern
fakten gestützt und hund dessen was wir
über die zeit jetzt erarbeitet haben
wenn sie mit jungen männern und mit
jungen frauen sprechen bevor sie kinder
bekommen
dann sagten die jungen männer in genau
der gleichen häufigkeit wie die jungen
frauen
ich möchte mich auch um ein kind kümmern
können ich möchte sehen wie es gross und
ich möchte nicht den fehler meines
vaters machen im alter immer sagt komm
hol dich darum und wie die kinder groß
werden sonst gehst du ganz ganz
wichtigen faktor in deinem leben und
auch hier wir keine chance und von daher
würde ich mich natürlich freuen wenn
männer mehr mutigen ihre visionen ihre
lebensentwürfe so wie sie sie häusern
dann tatsächlich auch durchzusetzen
gegenüber arbeitgebern die oft noch
nicht die bereitschaft haben die oft
noch präsenz mit karriere verbinden hier
sind einige kommentare die passen auch
ziemlich in die richtung
hier schreibt zum beispiel hightower es
ist aber definitiv auch wichtig dass der
vater ein kind mit erzieht oder
verdienen schreibt ich kümmere mich auch
in erheblichem umfang um unser kind also
hier sind auch einige männer mit in der
kommentarspalte unterwegs die das auch
so sehen und die anteil der
kindererziehung sein wollen
trotzdem finde ich hier auch kommentare
die gehen eher in die richtung frauen an
den herd das muss man tatsächlich sagen
ich muss mal kurz hier durch scrollen
und gucken ob ich ein finde ich hier zum
beispiel schreibt apple bei youtube wir
orientieren uns in krisenzeiten an
vertrauten mustern die sich über
jahrhunderte hinweg bewährt und ihre
wurzeln teilweise in den biologischen
unterschieden von mann und frau haben er
oder sie findet das nicht skandalös das
sind ja schon so eine so feste
rollenbilder die dann einfach da sind
vor allem dinge was kann jeder selbst
tun mann oder frau um auch ja damit
solche rollenbilder verschwinden
ich weiß dass wir diese gesten
rollenbilder haben wir machen ganz viele
untersuchungen wird zunächst bei zum
beispiel freien stellen eingeladen wird
zur vorstellung wir dann genommen wird
wir wissen wie die vorstandsetagen
aussieht das hat ganz ganz viel mit
rollenbilder zu tun
auch das leben lange zeit sagen frauen
sind die besser und leiterinnen was
meine sagten sogar nicht nachgewiesen
ist auch das ist natürlich in rollenbild
eine feste zuschreibung von
eigenschaften zu personen
wir können diese rollenbilder so gar
nicht sehen wir sehen dass diese
rollenbilder immer noch sehr starken und
strukturen drin sind ich habe heute
schon ein ganzes panorama sollten
strukturen genannt steuer wirtschaft um
gleiche löhne anreize zu hause zu
bleiben und so weiter und so fort
aber damit ist noch lange nicht gesagt
dass frauen männer ungleich sind und
damit ist noch lange nicht das recht zu
verweigern frauen eben gleichberechtigt
sich auch im arbeitsmarkt zu
verwirklichen zu sehen wie produktiv sie
sein können mit wie viel spaß sie bei
der arbeit sind mit wie viel wollen und
glück sie mit personen außerhalb ihrer
familie zusammen sind neue personen
kennenlernen
das sind alles ganz ganz wichtige
faktoren für männer wie für frauen und
dieses recht dürfen wir nicht verweigern
das ist sie mit beginnt auch gegen das
grundrecht und das muss man dann im
prinzip auch als frau vielleicht
in der eigenen partnerschaft einfordern
das muss man als frau tatsächlich so
einfach wie männer wenn ich sie jetzt
mal beim wort nehmen auch an müssen dass
sie andere lebensentwürfe haben als jene
sozusagen ununterbrochen im arbeitsmarkt
zu sein wir müssen unsere arbeitszeiten
ändern wir müssen uns überlegen ob wir
nicht mit einer 32 stunden woche für
alle über ein ganzes leben hinweg
arbeiten wo wir dann manchmal mehr
arbeiten manchmal weniger arbeiten sogar
mein leben
verlauf ich glaube wir leben noch in
abenteuerlich in zeiten wo wir
tatsächlich sagen die eine person macht
ausschließlich dass die andere person
macht aus lässt sich jenes das war
verbunden mit einer bildungssysteme das
waren das verbunden mit
wirtschaftssystemen diese zeiten sind
vorbei
wir wollten sie bitte nicht wieder
zurückhaltend
sie sprechen es schon an ich passen
einige kommentare auch in die richtung
war ich werd auch mit ihnen zu
dazugekommen darüber zu sprechen was
muss denn die politik verändern damit
wir mehr gleichberechtigung haben hier
schreibt schon zum beispiel lieber
facebook neue arbeitsmodelle erfinden
und anne preissner schreibt ebenfalls
bei facebook schlägt sie vor es gäbe ein
vorstoß von einem blog mama streikt
nennt er sich das auch care arbeit
gewürdigt und eben auch monetär
honoriert wird das würde uns in der
gleichberechtigung debatte weiter
bringen was hätten sie denn für
vorschläge was müsste sich an den
strukturen die wir momentan haben ändern
damit es mehr gleichberechtigung gibt
das erste ist dass wir
gleichberechtigung im moment passt aus
liest sich so sehen das weibliche leeb
nichts verläuft es sich von männlichen
anpassen
das halte ich für fatal da bin ich schon
ein kind habe dann möchte ich mich auch
um die kinder kümmern
als frau genauso wie der vater des
kindes das auch gemacht hat insofern
müssen wir mit den bezahlten
arbeitszeiten runter mit den unbezahlten
arbeitszeiten müssen männer hoch das
heißt eine angleichung der teilzeit oder
vollzeit arbeit zwischen männern und
frauen
wir müssen den faktor
verantwortungsvolle tätigkeit viel höher
gewichten damit bekommen wir es hin
dass frauen tätigkeiten einfach auf mehr
lohn in der stunde erwirtschaften
ebenso wie männliche erwerbstätigkeit
nicht denn er in industrie nach wie vor
sind wir müssen es erlaubten dass wir
flexibel arbeiten sowohl zu hause als
auch im büro
wir müssen schauen dass wir eine
qualitativ hochwertige und hoch
verlässliche kinderbetreuung hinbekommen
sowohl für die ganz kleinen kinder als
auch für die schulkinder
es sind alles maßnahmen die mir ganz
wichtig erscheinen die eigentlich auch
schon längst diskutiert schon längst auf
dem tisch legen und die umgesetzt werden
müssen insofern haben wir eigentlich
weniger erkenntnisproblem als handlungs
kollegen hier schreibt eine nutzerin
bianca verweist auf die besondere
situation von alleinerziehenden was
müsste passieren
alleinerziehende das spiel vielen dank
für dieses wort weil und den hinweis
auch alleinerziehenden die bis jetzt
noch gar nicht so weit zur sprache
gekommen sind
wenn wir unsere daten anschauen sind die
alleinerziehende tatsächlich jene für
100 so den ich am dreckigsten geht die
regeln die ich mir ansehen ressourcen
haben noch die zeitlichen ressourcen die
also zwischen baum und borke stehen
zwischen skylla und charybdis und sich
ganz alleine gelassen fühlen sich ja
auch nicht mehr mit ihren eltern oder
mit freundeskreise treffen können
aufgrund dieser wenn es ein
abstandsgebot
hier müssen wir ganz andere hips
faktoren die müssen wir auch andere
monetäre hilton in die hand nehmen weil
es da gar keinen anderen ausweg gibt
jenseits der besten infrastruktur und
lassen sie uns auch noch mal ganz kurz
auf strukturen schauen die es jetzt gibt
gerade ganz aktuell die ja vielleicht
gerade gegen die gleichberechtigung
arbeiten ich sage nochmal
ehegattensplitting was müsste sich denn
da tun wir können das ehegattensplitting
ändern in den familien stetigen dafür
gibt es ganz viele vorschläge von was
allen parteien auch die cdu-frauen war
und mein entsprechendes gemacht also
dadurch eine lange zeit fünf gibt diese
berliner erklärung dass dadurch dass das
dann wirklich von allen parteien
getragen wurde
dass ich dann auch was tut sind
natürlich umstellungsprobleme die sich
übernommen
zeitraum darstellen weil natürlich
ältere personen auch ein recht müssen
sich darauf verlassen zu können dass das
system so bleibt wie es ist
aber wir müssen endlich mal angehen so
dass die jungen familien unter anderen
rahmenbedingungen neben und nicht
permanente anreiz da ist dass frauen
weniger arbeiten weil sich dieses mehr
an arbeit letztendlich gar nicht in
haushaltseinkommen welches dann am ende
des monats auf dem tisch liegt zeigt das
ist für frauen dann insbesondere in der
rente portal sage immer es vor drei
jahren konnte ich das sagen dass frauen
eigentlich viel besser gefahren sind mit
einem heiratsmarkt unter den
abgeleiteten rente von männern die wir
höher als die eigene wirtschaft die
rente von frauen
das ist naja ich glaube ich kann diese
wertung einen schneeschauer rinnen und
zuhören überlassen wenn man so eine
gleichberechtigung schneit
also frau professor allmendinger ich
hasse jetzt mal zusammen eine lange
liste aus ihrer sicht was ich da tun
müsste für mehr gleichberechtigung wir
werden das thema natürlich im blick
behalten jetzt auch während der korona
krise und ganz herzlichen dank dass sie
sich die viele zeit genommen haben hier
die fragen zu beantworten
vielen dank für ihre fragen und vielen
dank auch das aufgreifen der fragen die
im netz kaum danke ja gerne und das dank
möchte ich natürlich auch an euch
richten das war wirklich eine ganz rege
diskussion vielen dank für die vielen
fragen und kommentare
nächste woche ist hier wieder daniel
bröckerhoff für euch da in der korona
sprechstunde
ich wünsche euch jetzt einen schönen
abend
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser leistung gefallen
hat dann gefällt euch vielleicht auch
dieser hier
da ging es darum warum so viele menschen
an corona verschwörungstheorien denken
oder ihr klickt man hier da haben wir
mit harald lesch darüber gesprochen wie
corona die welt verändert oder ihr lasst
uns einfach hier ein abo da das wird uns
freuen
[Musik]